le temps une de nos positions les plus précieuses il
nous a créé il nous fait vieillir il crée des
souvenirs il construit son histoire mais il
tue aussi il tue les vivants comme les plantes les
animaux les humains et il va aussi les non
vivants il endommage et détruit les
objets le temps tue l'art nous en avons trouvé plusieurs
façons de réparer des objets précieux certains
ont été très réussis comme en 2010
la chambre par un Dieu a été restaurée en
utilisant des couleurs contrastées fortes et
certains n'ont pas réussi du tout comme l'
artiste amateur en Espagne qui a détruit
la fresque HJ Homo du 19ème siècle avec la
réserve de l'Iowa  mais il y a une façon de
préserver que je trouve particulièrement
intéressante la liberté et
imaginer qu'on puisse réparer la Vénus
de Milo que faisait-elle de ses
mains notre goût Cosmo Wenman a
imaginé son fil qui tourne bien sûr
il peut réparer ils peuvent aussi protéger dans un
façon qui n'a jamais été faite avant que certains
musées aient été numérisés comme un
British Museum, nous pouvons parcourir les
expositions virtuellement en vue de la rue
permettent  En nous invitant à explorer les couloirs et les
galeries et en allant un peu plus loin
sur leur site Web, vous pouvez trouver des scans 3D
d'artefacts à télécharger et croyez-moi, les
scans 3D d'art et d'artefacts deviennent
assez courants. Sark est une organisation à but non
lucratif qui préserve
des sites d'irritation entiers qu'ils équilibrent.  la
lumière laser des surfaces d'endroits comme le
mantra shmore l'opéra de Sydney même
les huttes d'expédition antarctique les
scanners 3d mesurent des millions de points par
seconde avec une précision de quelques millimètres les
données collectées par SIA fourniront
des détails structurels complets qui
informeront la préservation de l'ensemble de la zone
tactile  sites pour l'avenir
et de nombreux facteurs créent le
besoin de préserver ces monuments et
artefacts endommagés par la pollution industrielle aux rayons UV
et même les gens en font
partie et cela va de la
façade en marbre du Taj Mahal qui avait été réchauffée
par les pluies acides l'homme  qui a repensé à
son lacet au Fitzwilliam Museum
de Cambridge et a brisé trois
p  les vases chinois sans riz du 17ème
siècle oups les
conflits sont depuis longtemps un ennemi de l'art
et des artefacts de la bibliothèque d'
Alexandrie les hommes de byron aziz qui brûlent des livres
ont détruit ce qui a pris des
siècles aux sociétés pour créer regardez ce qui se
passe au Moyen-Orient il y a
aussi  guerre incroyable du projet familial récurrent
Missoula,
ils utilisent des images de bénévoles et de
crowdsourcing pour créer des modèles, ils ont
commencé leur projet en réaction à
la destruction de sites patrimoniaux dans le
nord de l'Irak et au pillage et à la
vente au marché noir de parcelles tous les artefacts en
Irak Syrie et au-delà parce que  en effet la
préservation est aussi un formidable
outil politique quand les gens essaient de vous faire taire
car un artiste la numérisation est
généralement de votre côté fin
janvier dernier le célèbre artiste de rue Banksy a
réalisé une fresque de limas de hablar face à
l'ambassade de France à Londres  pour dénoncer
le traitement des personnes dans le
camp callee alors qu'elle n'a été
exposée que quelques heures cette pièce  de l'art
vivra pour la postérité grâce à Google
Streetview
préservé et accessible à tous donc la
cartographie et la documentation 3d nous permettent de
préserver et de protéger en transformant tous les
arts et le patrimoine en données
incurables et destructibles
si n'importe qui peut télécharger ces modèles et
reproduire ces pièces  pour eux-mêmes,
il ne s'agit pas seulement de réparer ou de
protéger, il s'agit aussi de partager et
il n'y a aucune limite à eux, vous pouvez
construire un musée chez vous si
vous êtes à la recherche d'un buste de jus, vous
pouvez librement imprimer le vôtre depuis votre canapé
si  nous avons tous ces œuvres d'art le
même produit par une imprimante en
plastique quelque chose après tout avec la
valeur la moins importante est-ce de l'art immobile
qu'en est-il de la préservation est-ce que l'art est créé
pour ressentir le temps d'y être soumis si nous
réparons la Vénus de Milo  voudriez-vous toujours le
voir Je suppose que beaucoup de gens votent
protéger et partager l'art fait partie de
notre devoir pour nous pour nos enfants
petits-enfants mais paradoxalement en
protégeant  ng et le partager pourrions-nous risquer de le
détruire Je ne me regarde pas comme
ça Je vous demande de me le faire savoir dans les
commentaires ci-dessous et prenez soin de vous
entrez dans notre prochaine discussion si vous voulez en
savoir plus sur l'art et la culture vous  pouvez
consulter notre chaîne, vous pouvez regarder plus de
vidéos et vous abonner si vous ne voulez
pas en manquer une